it's time for the ps+ mid Monon update
for November 2023 a bunch of games
coming to the extra catalog with a
spattering of premium and Deluxe Games 2
my job is to give you some gameplay and
an overview of each game while your job
is to decide what to play and maybe
leave a comment about the state of ps+
extra and premium deal deal I'm Adam
hello there here we go first a game
that's releasing today straight into the
extra catalog this is tear down the last
time I spoke about tear down I said it
was if Minecraft had a heist mode in
this single player sandbox we are given
jobs to retrieve objects and Escape
that's really the premise the real fun
is existing in these destructible
sandboxes if there's a wall in your way
how do you take it down carefully with a
sledgehammer maybe what about a wrecking
ball or an excavator tear down lets us
solve these little problems in our own
way the campaign strings together
scenarios and new areas with basic plot
points there's no deep story here it's
just enough to get get by early on
you'll be stealing a car from a
businessman and in the very next mission
the person you wronged hires you to
destroy the vehicle you took from them
as the objectives become more intensive
and strategic you'll be tested to the
full Can you steal everything and get
away before the popo arrive try it today
right now while you're downloading tear
down I'll take you through the other
games coming to the ps+ catalog on
November 21st okay let me mentally
prepare you for the rest of the games
coming it's not a great month at all
first we have Dragon's Dogma Dark Arisen
on the PS4 a very well respected action
RPG that was re-released with the Dark
Arisen expansions this comes as Dragon's
Dogma 2 is imminently releasing making
now a good time to relive the original
Fantasy RPG centered around the rebirth
of an ancient dragon that Dragon then
eats your heart and you want it back you
are the Arisen starting with a three
basic class system which then quickly
evolves allowing new and hybrid classes
to be created thus allowing players to
Define their own play style do you
prefer keeping your distance or getting
up close and personal Dragon's Dogma
Dark Arisen contains all the dlc's from
the original game making this an
absolutely packed complete bundle 11
years on gaming has changed quite a bit
but the combat still holds up by modern
standards average review score 81 out of
100 super Lial is the headliner for the
puzzle game fans in this firstperson
outing we stumble across many brain
teasers that require some thinking
outside the box p persective puzzles
which can only be solved by the correct
point of view and here's the twist each
object we interact with will grow and
Shrink thanks to our perspective it's a
really tough one to explain so I'm
hoping the video is helping with that as
members of Dr Pi's dream therapy program
we venture through many test rooms and
find a lovely little twist at the end of
the game a good thing about a month with
not much to choose from is that
hopefully more people will give super
Lial a chance following on from how
stacked last month was for horror gaming
is another Dead Island title this time
Rip Tide Definitive Edition the remaster
which takes us back to the island
paradise of Benoy only for it to be a
zombie apocalypse now the visceral melee
action is as gruesome and satisfying as
always and four-player Co-op is fully
supported in the sprawling open world
critics did not like riptide at all back
in 2013 averaging six out of 10 but if
you enjoy Dead Island and want more of
the same Riptide has got you back there
seems to be a trend of really old games
hitting extra this month you may have
noticed earlier this week that the PS5
version of Uno is now available and I
never realized that that would be a
highlight but it is it's one of the best
party games ever made it's the same as
the real life card game just without
your mate cheating and breaking the
rules there are also many variation DLCs
available to mix up the game play and
equal things out and Rabbids bro Rabbids
next we have a two on two battler Mobile
Suit Gundam Extreme versus Maxi boost on
an arcade fighter pitting iconic Gundam
against each other our x square triangle
and circle buttons relate to jump shoot
melee and search as the series has
updated many times over the years
they've added to the typical formula
teams can share health bars rather than
have their own and a growing number of
Gundams continue to be added each with
their own differing stats and preferred
fighting distances Mobile Suit Gundam is
a loved Series in Japan but it never
really hit those Heights in the west if
you'd like a retro inspired brawler
packed with ridiculous Sports mini games
may I suggest River City melee okay I
know it doesn't look great but for
something to play with a few of your
mates on ps+ it's actually pretty fun
beating the living snot out of your
friends whilst trying to score a goal
worthy of Lionel Messi has some definite
appeal it may only last you a few hours
but like most games play it with your
mates it's genuinely fun 30 teams 180
characters and 250 moves to master for
the role-play Fanatics take a look at a
uden Chronicle Rising the spiritual
successor to the sweeran series The 2D
Sid scrolling visuals are added to with
platform forming sections and loads of
combat is here as each member of your
team can be swapped in and out to
utilize their very specific move sets it
can look like a total free-for-all at
times but Rising is more than that as
your abilities suffer from cool down and
as your enemies rank up managing the
battlefield becomes integral to
progression it's a very well respected
game averaging scores of 75 out of 100
have you always wanted to try a
real-time Samurai strategy game yes you
have well today's your lucky day this is
Noble naga's ambition taii the 15th
entry in the series no less noble naga's
ambition Prides itself on recreating
historical battles and retelling the
stories of this time period in great
detail we control entire armies and must
coordinate attacks between units to
minimize loss and maximize progression
on top of the realtime strategy points
can be placed into researching tasks
which could result in technology
becoming available before your
competitors anyway you win every war
with Pinter attacks finally on extra
this month alternative Jake Hunter dust
The Awakening of gold Jazz and no those
words aren't made up that's a real game
we must discover who unived our
grandfather while he lived in New York
City in this interactive narrative drama
as always each month games continue to
leave the catalog in less than 7 Days in
fact thankfully the list this time isn't
as brutal as previous months on November
21st say Tata to my time at Porsche seen
as a worthy alternative to stardew
Valley see you later Giana sisters
Twisted dreams directors of Edition also
say goodbye to Ace of seafood I can't
believe I didn't get to play that
momodora Ry under the Moonlight connect
tank wild guns reloaded and dandera
trials of fear edition if you want to
play those games hurry up they'll become
locked on the 21st of November okay
let's quickly go over the classic
lineups for you guys who have Deluxe or
premium subscriptions grandia the
classic PS1 RPG which pushed the
boundaries of 3D rendering back then is
here for you to try we play as Justin a
young boy destined to be a great
Adventurer After he finds a Magic Stone
next is Jet Moto another PS1 game that's
a cross between Moto GP wave racer and
road rash PaRappa the Rapper 2 joins the
classics a rhythm game with the most
iconic video game character of all time
I've missed you for rapper Disney and
Pixar up the video game is here from the
PSP era and finally a belter of a series
cloa fantasy revery series is here on
your PS4 and 5 celebate in 25 years of
cloa from the PS1 and PS2 eras if there
was something to recommend in premium
it's definitely this so that's our month
please do me a favor leave me a like I
don't pick these games I just tell you
about them I'm Adam you are awesome it's
been a pleasure hopefully my voice
hasn't been annoying this time around
I'm trying to get through flu right now
I'm Adam you're awesome see
you